at the age of 12 I started experiencing
some gender dysphoria and
I started seeing a therapist and I got
the diagnosis and I started going
on the path of medical transition at the
age of 13 starting with blockers and
then
moving on to hormones and at 15 I got a
double mastectomy but what is that it
turned out that it vasectomy is having
your breasts removed no at 15 yeah
horrible
the best decision for me and I stopped
transitioning at the age of 16.
okay so let's go back to when you were
let's go back to when you were 12. about
when
I just can't listen it just came off
it's so weird
I love him let's go back to when you
were 12. I love his voice he's just like
it's just straight jokes listening to
them he's amazing all right let's get
Let's Get Serious let's get surgical
styling you hit puberty
um I had a fairly early puberty actually
started um I started developing at
at around the age of nine if not a
little bit earlier wow okay okay and so
um so at nine did that it is
um I gotta forget I read it a long time
about it a long time ago but a lot of it
has to do with the hormones that they
put into
um dairy cows and and food so that they
produce faster so then those hormone
residues get passed on to us makes sense
makes perfect sense indeed I remember um
so girls are developing I hit puberty
later and I thought I was just you know
when you're like 13 and you're like
still peach fuzz you're like you know my
life's over that's what you think
I was late too you you get that
genetically but means maybe it means
that yeah pictures of me in high school
I look like I'm like nine maybe one or
seventy we'll look like we're 60. yeah
you know it'll work out yeah I know some
of your friends are like walking in with
like big hairy man pubes all over their
legs and you were just still a kid
okay okay and so
um
so at nine did that do you remember if
that changed you emotionally
yeah it did I
it was really difficult for me actually
okay so let me give you a little
background you tell me if anybody's ever
told you this before Okay so
boys and girls
experience before puberty experience
approximately the same levels of
negative emotion so that would be
primarily anxiety and emotional pain or
even sometimes susceptibility to
physical pain and emotions like
frustration and disappointment and shame
and guilt and self-consciousness are all
part of that what would you call it
network of negative emotion
and what happens to girls when they hit
puberty and no one knows exactly why
this is is that there are negative
emotion levels go up
and so that on average women
biologically mature women are more
sensitive to negative emotion than
biologically mature men and that kicks
in at puberty now there's a variety of
explanations for that but no one knows
for certain and here's some of them okay
so first of all
sexual dimorphism and physical strength
really
emerges at puberty so boys and girls are
pretty evenly matched physically but
once puberty kicked look at this suit
this man's looking fly
sin boys are taller stronger heavier and
they're much stronger in terms of upper
body strength so women are at a
disadvantage
physically in relationship to anything
that might have to do with physical
combat and so on those grounds it makes
sense for women to be somewhat more
sensitive to threat
okay so then the another explanation is
that
women are more vulnerably sexually than
men because they bear a much higher cost
for reproduction obviously with
pregnancy and protracted dependence of
infants and so it makes
so they're they're more vulnerable on
the sexual front so it makes it it makes
sense for them to be more sensitive to
any threat that's associated with sexual
activity and then the third explanation
and there may be more is that
women are I love the way he explains
stuff it all just makes like completely
perfect sense yeah like that just makes
perfect sense why girls would be more
like you boys because like you know like
if some [__] happens like there's like
legit serious consequences yeah it's not
like a guy it's it's the it's the
opposite and you know just that this is
this this is research that these doctors
all have access to and yet they're just
telling girls that they need to cut off
body parts and take hormones and do
puberty blockers um that's something
it's it's really disturbing like nobody
explained this to her I mean I could
without this knowledge just knowing
myself and all of the girls that I grew
up with from because I went to the same
Elementary School from kindergarten
through the eighth grade so we all went
through this together from kindergarten
I can tell you it's just a really
awkward hard stage and did anybody ever
just yeah you don't need you don't need
to do any really deep scientific
research to know that puberty sucks for
everybody because nobody's going through
the same phase at exactly the same time
you've got a group of you know three or
four girls one girl is like getting sexy
and getting attention from guys and the
other ones over in the corner looking
like howdy Duty no I know and in the
moment you know you think that that's
your life forever like if you're a
little bit awkward at 13 you're just
like oh [__] that's it or like if you
know I'm sure it's the same for girls
like you said like you saw other girls
developing and you're like well I guess
I'm never getting boobs I'm just done
like no one's ever gonna like me it's
like bruh shut up you're 13. right and I
don't know what they went through but I
can tell you for sure that they weren't
mentally and emotionally equipped to
deal with what they were going through
either yeah you know nobody nobody knew
what the hell was going on because our
brains were just four years past being
nine-year-olds yeah you don't you know
what do you know just learned how to
read and write and we're trying to
figure things out and for somebody to
not just tell her this is normal it is
normal to just be in a bug out for these
years of your life yeah it's tough for
everybody and some people fake it better
some people skate through a little bit
better on the outside but it's hard on
the inside for everybody and that's so
sad what they're doing to children that
they're not just telling them hey
yeah being a teenager kind of sucks but
it's going to be over and then you have
the rest of your life we're just enjoy
it enjoy like yeah just enjoy you know
do you like if I could go back to
seventh grade where I'm just playing
Call of Duty Black Ops 3 Zombies with
the boys eating cookies like bruh OG
fortnite come on I'm going you know what
I'm glad you said that because you did
you did enjoy it and I enjoyed it too in
my life like I had some angst but I
loved High School I was hustling I was I
had my little entrepreneurial Ventures I
was running up candy and school lemonade
stands shoveling you chose social media
accounts I was grinding I was flipping
Supreme remember I was flipping stuff
back in the day that was a little bit of
a project I'm glad that's over yeah that
was that was a pain in the ass because I
had to use your card I didn't even have
a debit card that was lit though all
right I had to go pack [__] up and mail
it for you and that was annoying okay
but charge generally speaking with the
primary responsibility for infants and
infants are extremely dependent and
vulnerable
and so you could make a case that adult
women's nervous systems are actually
adapted for the mother child dyad and
not for the say emotional well-being of
the individual woman
and a woman needs to be threat sensitive
because she's going to be taking care of
infants and an extremely dependent
children and it makes sense for her to
be more cognizant of threats as a
consequence even though the negative
consequence of that for women and all of
this is that women are much more likely
to suffer from depression and anxiety
than men
cross-culturally it's between three to
one and five to one now men have their
Associated pathologies men are more
likely to be anti-social for example and
to abuse alcohol but women predominate
on the negative emotion side and so
and then I would say that's exacerbated
you know if you hit puberty early
because you have to deal with these
complexities of physiological
transformation at a very young age and
so that's a difficult thing to handle
emotionally and then there's the
additional consequence of whatever
hormonal uh turbulence might emerge as a
consequence of the onset of puberty so
it's very common for young women
to experience high levels of negative
emotion and for those emotions to be
focused on their body because another
thing that's characteristic of female
negative emotion is that the
self-consciousness associated with that
tends to focus very particularly on body
shame and self-consciousness and that
might be because women are evaluated
more rigorously on the basis of their
physical appearance than men men are
evaluated more harshly sexually let's
say on the performance side you know
with regard to socioeconomic status and
so forth but women are definitely
evaluated more harshly by men and by
each other in terms of their physical
attractions so that makes part of it you
as at that age it's all your whole world
is in your head you're all everything is
about you you haven't even developed the
I don't even know what to call it but
the awareness habit of you know being
aware of how other people feel what
other people are going through I know
this award for items spazzing on it but
you're just it's me me me me this is how
I feel so you can't even look around as
a kid and be like oh you know there's
some other people that are probably
going through this unless they come to
you you know and that's so that
exacerbates these problems
on top of everything that he's saying
indubitably exactly far more eloquence
and intelligence
that's wicked complicated
situation for girls who are making the
transition into puberty and a lot of
them are depressed and anxious and that
and develop an intense focus on their
body so I don't know how much of that
was explained to you by your therapists
or the medical professionals but that's
all well that's all well-documented
psychological and medical information
yeah none of that was really explained
to me
by therapist or even growing up I mean
even so that all
every single part of what you said
actually played a role in
a lot of my childhood distress and my
transition and eventually my ID
transition actually you know um
growing up I was a bit of a tomboy and
also on the Spectrum and I didn't know
this until I was diagnosed just last
year but it did play a role in my my
socialization and my difficulty getting
along with other girls growing up and I
found that I fit in more of the boys and
when I hit puberty um that's pretty
crazy that she went from being tomboy to
dressing like um a nine-year-old
schoolgirl
like I'm not saying that is a chirp like
I'm just saying you look like like you
got the double ponytails you got the the
pink [__] on like you look like you're
in a little girl like she's to go it's
ironic it's who knows what the cause of
that is maybe it's like a sort of an
attempt to stay young and recapture
youth that she threw you see what I'm
saying all right I'm not being crazy
she's extremely modest too in her dress
like she is very clearly not looking to
draw too much attention to her body yeah
it was a bit earlier than most of my
peers and I got taller than them and
oh yeah you know I I could keep up with
the boys then and I had a lot of pride
in that but as the years went on they
started to get taller than me and
outmatched me physically and this did
bring on a bit of distress for me and um
you know as I got older
um socialization become began to become
more
sex oriented and
I found it even harder to fit in with
girls my age and but at the same time I
was also starting to notice there was a
divide between me and boys
um in several ways and
there was there was a lot of loneliness
for me because on one hand I didn't
really feel like I was I was one of the
girls but on the other hand I was right
losing my connection with some of my
friends who I
was close to it and really really cared
about so many people and the fact that
this girl felt like it was such a solo a
unique experience is so sad yeah maybe
she's autistic now because of all the
[__] they gave her like might have had
to do with it but what do I know you
know yeah we don't we don't have enough
information to know it's autism like do
they look in your brain and they're like
you have neurons that aren't firing
properly or did they just say these
behavioral things signify that you have
I thought it was a behavioral analysis
but I really don't know I I think it is
but scientifically speaking they say
it's because neurons don't fire right or
some [__] I'm not a scientist for what
there is to know about the nervous
system and the Brain we know we don't
know [__] we don't know [__] that's
right do we even understand
Consciousness because if you're thinking
about this from like a science
perspective like if you what you're
thinking is like code or like how we how
we analyze stuff it's like this happens
and it causes this so if you're thinking
something it would mean that like these
nerves are firing in your brain causing
you to think this right but if that's
not the thing if like if that's not what
it is then do we even understand how you
like I know they do those brain scans
where you can see parts of the brain
lighting up and it based on different
stimuli and pain and pleasure and all
that but let's see if we can let's see
what we can find out about that and
maybe do watch a video on that because I
think it's just a really cool question I
feel like we just like don't know [__]
you know well yeah but then I feel like
but you're not the first person to ask
that question and they're they're really
qualified scientists asking that
question and looking for that answer so
let's see the scientists they don't know
[__] either and then in 20 years we can
watch that video and then laugh about
yeah look at this dumb 19 year old son
me no no but it's funny that like I
recognize we don't know [__] about
humans and then I'll watch like a nature
documentary and we're like and the
Elephant has this and this and then they
think this and they know that I'm like
you don't know [__] about elephants have
you talked to one you know you don't
know a damn thing about elephants or
like octopuses and dolphins who are
really smart I'll watch documentaries on
them and they'll be explaining all about
them and I'm like you know nothing you
don't know [__] about them you know what
I'm saying though there's so much more
it can be known they know they know a
lot you know [__] they also had some
body image issues growing up as well
um
than we are honey I often talk about how
social media played a role in it but
really it started from a very young age
actually everybody has this pain and
these poor kids have someone going over
and being like you know I have that pain
because that thing needs to be cut off
that body part we need to cut it off we
need to give you this medicine so that
you stop you stop she's 18 to a boy wow
that's horrible this poor girl is is
like seconds out of trauma so she we
need to talk to her again in another 10
years and then in another 10 years after
that and God willing she'll be normal
and by then she'll be married and have
children and be happy because she I've
seen other videos about her where she is
concerned about whether she can even
have children she knows for sure she
would not not be able to breastfeed
because she cut her tits out yeah I mean
that sucks thank God she didn't cut her
uterus out I see some of them doing that
now yeah that's like I grew I was a
little dumb I was born into a very image
oriented very sex-oriented society and
you know before I hit puberty I was
looking forward to having a developed
body and eventually going breasts
and you know once I hit puberty and once
I hit puberty I was
it wasn't what I expected and fake boobs
you can get them but they're not the
same they're not real boobs no I don't
even know if she still has her nipples
because sometimes they take those off
too have you ever felt a fake boob like
a friend
I have not I definitely haven't but if I
had to guess I'd know they're they're
they don't feel the same yeah I don't
know I
don't know I was really quite
disappointed how I looked I was very
very skinny I was on the smaller chested
side and you know I grew up in an age
where you were like 45 bodies that are
very
um
very voluptuous lots of Curves people
often use a phrase like body I mean
bottom heavy or hourglass
pear-shaped things like that and I
didn't look like that at all I was you
know I was I was quite thin a little on
the muscular side and if anything my
shoulders
probably the widest point in my body
and I kind of had a complex over this I
I also liked having my hair shortened
because of all this I felt like if
anything I didn't really look like a
girl at all I didn't like the other I
didn't look like the other girls my age
and I felt like
I just wasn't pretty in that do you
think her The Voice definitely changed
since that stuff right I think that I
probably had something to do with the
yeah it doesn't sound like a very
feminine the deeper voices because of
the hormone therapy I would never
it's it's a very rare Adolescent and
probably a particularly rare female
adolescent who feels attractive in the
early stages of puberty yes you know so
everything that you experienced although
you may have experienced it you know in
an exaggerated manner for some of the
reasons you laid out but everything you
experienced is in some real sense par
for the course for for a few years for
the vast majority of people now you did
add one additional issue which we could
delve into a little bit which I think is
relevant so you said that you're on the
Spectrum and that you had an easier time
communicating with boys than with girls
and so here's something to know about
that so does everything the biggest
reliable difference that's being
documented between males and females and
this becomes even larger in egalitarian
societies by the way
is orientate how does a liberal that
thinks gender isn't even real watch this
because he's talking about scientific
differences between men and women but
they genuinely don't even acknowledge
that some of these people so how do you
even watch this like what what goes what
what synapses are firing in their brain
watching this when he's talking about
this so they just think he's a monster
you know what I'm saying like that's
crazy I'm I'm trying to wrap my head
around it what is a woman someone who
thinks they're a woman you shouldn't
have interest so women are higher in
negative emotion and they're more
agreeable and agreeableness is both
compassion and politeness and although
the difference between men and women
isn't massive
um it's significant and it also
maximizes an egalitarian society so it
looks like it's biological but the
biggest difference is in interest
and uh boys males are more reliably
interested in things
and girls females are more reliably
interested in people
but people on the autistic Spectrum are
also more reliably interested in things
and so for example if you're extremely
autistic the psychological uh phrase for
autistic thinks is more why might be
more interested in things than
Associates that with her commonalities
with men with biological men and then
thinks that she might be a boy wait what
do boys what things are boys obsessed
with he just made General a general
statement I'm just trying to like
because I don't understand that like
girls are more obsessed I thought girls
would be more obsessed with things no
girls love cars men cars trucks boats
horses motorcycles mechanics I guess I
don't know interesting I would like to
hear deeper explanation of that the
psychological uh phrase for for
descriptive purposes is lacking theory
of mind and so extremely autistic people
have a hard time understanding what's
going on in someone else's mind at all
they they tend to be almost entirely
thing oriented and there's a much higher
preponderance of autistic symptoms among
engineers and then if engineers in
Silicon Valley for example male
engineers and female Engineers often
by statistical comparison often Mary and
their children are disproportionately
likely to be autistic and so the fact
that you are tilted towards the the
autistic end of the spectrum first of
all that might just be an indication of
uh neurological wiring that tilts you
towards interest in things just so you
know that so that's not necessarily
autistic in and of itself it's what this
guy 800 000 subs and I have 200 000 and
I'm [__]
I don't know bro this YouTube [__]
beats me man it's just part of the
normal variation in in what would you
call it
well in attentional orientation but the
fact that you were
on the Spectrum let's say and more
interested in things is going to make it
more difficult for you to communicate
with girls because girls are reliably
more interested in people and so and
then on the image front you know this
this ties in with
the idea of self-consciousness so
if you're on stage and you're talking to
people it makes so much and uh you
become aware of yourself tends to make
you nervous and sweat and to uh become
uncomfortable to experience high levels
of negative emotion and
self-consciousness itself looks like a
manifestation of negative emotion
they're incredibly tightly linked
statistically almost indistinguishable
from one another and so what you see
happening very often in girls because
girls are self-conscious in relationship
to their body because that's one of the
primary ways they're assessed let's say
for attractiveness and for social status
is that that self-consciousness tends to
take the form of intense preoccupation
with body and with image and so that can
be exacerbated by whatever social trends
happen to be in place but it's it's a
very deep-seated problem and so that's
part of and also the fact that you hit
puberty earlier is going to make that
obviously is going to make that more
complicated because it means you're not
as
neurologically or practically this girl
is in a perfect storm of not being fully
not having her brain developed enough to
handle what's going on having all these
possibly autistic Tendencies hormonal
you know spikes that she can't
understand development physical
development at an age when of course
women are more judged on their on their
physique and an age when she can't
understand it so she has this perfect
storm of all these feelings swirling
around her and confusion and then these
vultures come in and convince her that
what's going on is that she's not really
even even a female yeah and we're gonna
and we're gonna mutilate your body at a
time when you cannot in a way that you
can never recover from because when
you're 14 years old you know enough to
decide that what exactly what you want
for the rest of your life that's what
they're telling these young these young
people and this is a this is an epidemic
these people belong in jail doctors who
swore to protect and heal and to do no
harm first Do no harm is is I believe
the very first line of the Hippocratic
Oath that doctors take about their
ethics and how they're going to practice
medicine wow and this is so harmful so
harmful this is this is on freaking
believable that this is a conversation
that has become so huge in this country
that we have to now put laws in place in
certain places to stop people from
mutilating children sure when you have
to contend with all these issues
so everything that you described in some
sense could have been attributed to the
difficulties of normative development
just just so you know and this is
proclivity of teenagers to development
translating Jordan Peterson's basically
this 10 minutes view you were growing up
as a normal kid guy that [__] sucks yeah
sometimes [__] sucks it's hard being
[__] sucks nobody sucks that's it that
this whole video could have been
sometimes [__] sucks don't cut off your
tits
could have just yes I would have done it
anxiety I want to take that apart for a
minute too for everybody who's listening
so imagine
gender dysphoria
okay so 10 years ago it was imperatively
rare but not unheard of but imagine it
has two components okay
one is a tendency towards negative
emotion so suffering anxiety depression
frustration disappointment pain shame
guilt self-consciousness all of that
and then imagine there's a sec second
part of it that's more specifically
focused on discomfort with the body
okay the first part of that
is the bulk of it so if you look across
forms of Psychopathology like mental
illness
the major segment is high levels of
negative emotion like depression and
anxiety
and a secondary segment is the
particular manifestation of that in your
case in body dysmorphia and so and then
the the claims that
uninformed mental health professionals
make that you're at elevated risk for
suicide if you're gender dysphoric is
erroneous because the elevated risk for
suicide is actually a consequence of the
of the general proclivity for depression
and anxiety and not a specific
consequence of the gender dysphoria or
at least that's only a small
sub-component of it
and so that's another thing to know is
that
it's like you got a really big bad tumor
in your lung and it's CR and it's
growing and it's slowly gonna stop you
from breathing eventually you think it's
from something but it's from the
cigarettes or something but the doctor
is gonna treat you know the the wound
the wart you have on your pinky because
the wart you know is is ugly and you can
see it and so we got to take care of the
wart but ignore the fact that you've got
tumors growing in your lungs that are
going to suffocate you so we're blaming
it on the wrong [__] okay so they're so
they're treating they're ignoring the
bulk of the problem and treating a
little wart on your on your pinky and
makes perfect sense good job
pathological manifestation mental
illness is centered on heightened levels
of negative emotion and of course that
spikes I hope so for adolescent girls
now
you you may have been told this but
perhaps you weren't so there are good
long-term
studies of children with gender
dysphoria most of them were conducted in
Toronto where I happened to be by a man
named Ken Zucker and Zucker ran a
a clinic for gender dysphoric kids way
before this became part of the culture
War let's say and he was a very straight
and honest scientist a very good
researcher not a political person and
what he showed was
what his Clinic showed many
peer-reviewed studies was that
gender dysphoria of the type that you
described is relatively rare
but if you leave kids alone
till they're 19 or 18 80 to 90 percent
of them settle into their biological
identity
although about 80 percent of them also
are also homosexual in their orientation
and so the pathway
for him
before this was all politicized was
you'd have a child who was
gender non-conforming temperamentally
somewhat like you were
you didn't have a pattern of female
interests let's say and so and then
prone to depression and anxiety and then
that combination would produce this
gender dysphoria and that would become
quite intense around the dawn of puberty
but if you just back the hell off and
waited
those kids would settle into their body
but generally I adopted homosexual
orientation
it's pretty straightforward
that's pretty simple so I saw another
video with that girl and she was talking
about how she started with puberty
blockers then moved into hormone therapy
and then got the double mastectomy where
she had both of her breasts removed and
it was shortly within a year after that
first of all there's a lot of difficulty
there's a lot of infection and you're
constantly changing your bandages and
actually I don't even think it was a
year but she she shortly thereafter
started to really regret it and started
to think what did I do so at 15 she had
her breasts cut off and at 16 she
stopped the detransition and she was
taking testosterone and um she said that
her you know she just quit it cold
turkey and that really created a whole
flurry of other problems for her
couldn't imagine uh she had one Doctor
Who during the hormone therapy phase
tried to explain to her that this could
this could affect her brain development
in the long run that there wasn't enough
evidence to show so there was a w doctor
that tried to get her not to do this
[__] yeah and they they the transition
doctors pulled her away from that doctor
and sent them sent her to a doctor so
there's actually doctors with them
that's crazy that there's doctors that
like specialize in like kids
transitioning oh wait let me pull up
let's let's show let's show the people
this trans women
vaginoplasty so that's you getting
getting a veg put on is this a trans
yeah
genital surgery breast augmentation I
don't even Metroid oplasty I don't know
what that is follow does that mean you
grow a peach female to male uh we stop
gender affirming procedure for the low
body that's designed to construct a
phallus from existing genital tissue so
they take your hoo-hoo and they turn it
into a nullification nullification here
let's let's just read if you have an
image in your mind of what you want your
body to look like our team's here to
help you achieve it we offer numerous
non-binary surgery surgeries including
genital nullification that could help
you reach your goals with the removal of
all genital tissue we create a
relatively smooth genital area with a
soft transition from the lower abdomen
to the groin will also shorten your
urethra along with other
patient-specific additions learn more
about our options I'm done reading that
that's no that's Haram Haram
thank you guys so much for watching make
sure to like subscribe follow me on
Instagram at sunnyfast join my Discord
and I'll see you later
[Music]